الصواريخ الروسيه دمرت البيوت
واثارت الهلع في وسط سكان النائمين
في ساعه صباح الاولى استخرج الانقاذ خمس
جثث في هذه المنطقه من الفيف على بعد 800
كيلومتر من جبهات القتال
قيلت ثلاث ساعات سقط وابل من الصواريخ على
نحو 10 مدن اوكرانيه
اما في كييف فاحترقت محطه للكهرباء في
الفجر فيما اصيب حي سكني في المدينه
كنت عائدا الى البيت ومره صاروخ فوق راسي
سمعت صوته ثم اعقبه انفجارا
في خاركيب احداث الصاروخ هذه الحفره
الواسعه دون احداث خسائر بشريه وفي خرسون
جنوبا قتل ثلاثه اشخاص في محطه حافلات
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه نشرت هذه الصور
لصواريخ تطلق من مدينه بيلكرود الناطق
باسم الوزاره قال ان الصواريخ المستعمله
خارقه للصوت وهي الصواريخ التي لا يمكن ان
تكتشفها الدفاعات الجويه الاوكرانيه
الرئيس الاوكراني ندد بالهجوم
حاول العدو ترهيبه الاوكرانيين باستعمال
تكتيكه البائس الجديد
هذه الضربات المتناسقه اثارت القلق في
زابوريجيا مع انقطاع شبكه الكهرباء عن
المحطه الكهربائيه النوويه تقع المحطه في
منطقه تسيطر عليها القوات الروسيه وظل
تعمل لساعات بفضل مولدات كهربائيه